people mentioned before a right-angle so
from here from the parallelogram there's
a couple of things we could do so I want
you to imagine taking this parallelogram
and you're I showed you those on this
wooden sticks last lesson that we can
prove the sides around so I want you to
take these to society like what it
stinks so that you've got a 90 degree
angle what would happen to your
parallelogram it would become a
rectangle right we will get to this
square from this okay so you can see
here he's my rectangle it has the same
properties that the parallelogram has as
we go from left further involved to the
right you're getting all of the things
before plus new stuff right so I still
have my equal sides sorry my parallel
sides I still bet parallel sides I still
on my equal sides
but now I've added here a right angle
okay now what's really cool about this
is just like before see how here what we
added it intentionally was parallel
sides and then for free you get equal
sides right well when you add one right
angle you'll notice everything else also
it becomes a right angle you add one and
you get the other three for free it's
like buy one get three free that's not a
bad deal right
so I've added the right angle but in
fact I get full okay and this is our
this is our old familiar rectangle okay
now once you remember when we went from
the quadrant I talked for the trapezium
to the parallelogram right what we had
was one pair of parallel sides and then
two pairs of parallel sides
well now I've got like soup hairs of
equal sides one would be a natural next
step to evolve this shape apart from
adding a writing or what else could we
do yeah boy yeah fantastic
not just that I've got pears that are
equal but what if the pears were equal
to each other
right so now I'm gonna say it what I'm
gonna add is both pairs equal to each
other
okay so I already had a pair equal and a
pair equal and now the pair's themselves
are equal okay so what shape we're gonna
get now I did here I did if you get
mentioned before remember I haven't got
the right angle yet cuz that's over this
way all right I'm gonna get a rhombus so
it's gonna look like this okay it looks
like this and I've got equal sides but I
also have all the other stuff that the
parallelogram had mainly those parallel
sides like that and like that okay now
two things before we move to the very
last step because you can see I'm on the
fourth corner I should name it like we
said rhombus it's got a um silent H okay
you often see rhombuses you know in
primary school sometimes you call them
diamonds right you'll often see rhombus
is drawn like this like they're standing
up I've deliberately drawn it the same
way to help you see there's another
evolution on the board that I kind of
haven't connected yet I've tried to draw
them in a similar way so that you can
kind of see the similarity you would see
yeah very good you see the color right
it's got those two pairs that are equal
to each other than or equal rather but
now there's kind of like a line going
from there to there right yeah it does
it does look the same the rhombus just
like being a souped up version of
parallelogram the rhombus is also a
souped up version of the kite okay
before we leave off that and draw the
last shape I will for a tip will show
you things that the kite has that the
rhombus has get your rule around you
have to be very careful with this if
you've drawn your kite well and this
sign is such sure not equal this side of
this side screwed up equal you can
measure see how close you are now what
I'd like you to put on there is the
diagonals of the kite do all the dials
are done very carefully
in this okay diagonals now if you join
your diagonals well you should see
there's something special about those
diagonals right they they meet right
there they meet at 90 degrees there's a
right angle of it they're perpendicular
okay not only are they perpendicular
what can you see you seen this one
across the top right can you see it's
kind of big split in two can you see
that we have a special word for that we
call that bisected right it's divided
into two so we have this side here this
part of the diagram is equal to this
part of day okay that's kind of neat you
can prove that too we won't go into it
but I just want to show you now since a
rhombus is a special kind of kite is to
do the same thing with the dangles let's
do them again down the middle like that
and then across the middle because the
rhombus is just like the kite
number one there's the right angle again
and number two there's also this being
split this way but because the rhombus
is even more special than the kite
there's something else you notice yeah
yeah very good here
one of the diagonals were split in half
one of the diagonals was bisected but he
are both diagonals bisect it I'm looking
to do four lines because it starts to
get a bit open
I checked you two two times I skipped
over to there you go
in fact my rhombus is not very rhombus
see you can see it's not quite but yours
you've got yes that's right all sides
are here and the diagonals are going
bisectors okay you can start to see our
diagrams are getting very crowded aren't
they that's because the more special
your quadrilateral gets the more cool
stuff there is enough okay
lost step last step
do you remember to go from here to here
we add in a right angle and to go from
here to here we made the signs all equal
to each other okay so now I want you to
think about what happens if you add a
right angle to this if you add a right
angle to this add a 90-degree angle okay
what you will end up with is our final
evolution a final version right the
square okay you can see it's just like
they'll roll this in that you've got all
the sides equal right you've got the
right angles now okay you have all of
those parallel things
this guy's parallel to this one this
one's parallel this one if you want to
you can also draw your diagonals in okay
this side the diagonals just like in the
rhombus the diagonals are perpendicular
but now because this shape is even more
special than all the other ones right
not only are these diagonals both
bisected but mission the diagonals
whether you measure the diagonals with
your ruler you'll find that this
diagonal is equal to this side right see
you got this guy and this guy and this
guy and this guy it's like everything is
it cool okay
all right mr. pett again it's not quite
everything is also by these videos yeah
kind of now there's one more thing I
forgot to make sure it right I can get
to the square I can get to the square by
taking a rhombus and adding a right
angle but that's not the only way I can
get to the square right
sometimes a shape can involve in more
than one way so you can see if I go from
the rectangle
what must I add to a rectangle to turn
it into a square inside answer both dear
but this besides these these are already
equal
but if make more legal right both pairs
of sides equal each other you can see
all roads lead to that's where okay and
that is the most special quadrilaterals
of them all